This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Long time beautiful nerds know that we have a thing for flags how they're made what they symbolize What makes a good flag and a bad flag? So with another flag day coming up today's story is about a flag that you're definitely familiar with One that we're probably long overdue covering on this show the flag of the United States that were probably long overdue covering on this show. The flag of the United States. Actually, Roman the story I'm here with today is less about the flag itself and more about
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。长期的“美丽书呆子”们都知道，我们对旗帜情有独钟——它们是如何制作的，它们象征着什么，什么造就了一面好旗帜，什么又造就了一面坏旗帜？随着又一个旗帜日的临近，今天的故事是关于一面你绝对熟悉的旗帜，一面我们可能早就该在这个节目中介绍的旗帜——美利坚合众国的国旗。其实，罗曼，我今天带来的故事与其说是关于旗帜本身，不如说是关于
its origin story. As reporter Lizzie Peabody, she hosts a podcast for the Smithsonian that's like our spiritual cousin, it's called Side Door. Most Americans probably feel like they know the story of where our flag came from. And you might have learned this back in the fourth grade too, Roman.
它的起源故事。记者莉齐·皮博迪（Lizzie Peabody）为史密森尼学会主持着一档播客，就像我们的精神表亲一样，它叫《侧门》（Side Door）。大多数美国人可能觉得他们知道国旗的来历。罗曼，你可能在四年级的时候也学过这个。
The Betsy Ross story? Yeah, I think people are probably familiar with the elementary school version of the Betsy Ross story, but we're going to ruin that story and hopefully replace it with a better one. Yes, but before we ruin it, let's do a quick recap because it might have been a few, I don't know, decades since some of us were in elementary school. So, Roman, I brought this picture with me to refresh your memory. Yes, I between the drawing of Betsy Ross in Schoolhouse Rock and this painting, my entire image of what Betsy Ross is is from those two images. And in this painting, it's her sitting in this big booby dress next to an open window. There's like beautiful light pouring in. And at the bottom of the painting,
贝齐·罗斯（Betsy Ross）的故事？是的，我想人们可能对小学课本里的贝齐·罗斯故事很熟悉，但我们要毁掉那个故事，并希望用一个更好的故事来取代它。是的，但在我们毁掉它之前，让我们快速回顾一下，因为距离我们当中一些人上小学可能已经过去，我不知道，几十年了。所以，罗曼，我带了这张照片来帮你唤醒记忆。是的，在《学校摇滚》（Schoolhouse Rock）中贝齐·罗斯的画作和这幅油画之间，我脑海中关于贝齐·罗斯的全部形象都来自这两张图。在这幅画里，她穿着一件蓬蓬裙，坐在开着的窗户旁边。美丽的阳光倾泻而入。在画的底部，
it reads, Birth of our nation's flag. Yes. And in this painting, you see George Washington and these two other guys in Wigs from the Continental Congress. And the story goes that they commissioned Betsy Ross to design a new flag for this new nation that was about to come out of the Revolutionary War
写着“我们国家国旗的诞生”。是的。在这幅画中，你可以看到乔治·华盛顿和另外两个戴着假发的来自大陆会议的人。故事是这样说的：他们委托贝齐·罗斯为这个即将从独立战争中诞生的新国家设计一面新旗帜，
free of British rule. And these guys and wigs are kind of looking at George Washington sort of waiting to see his reaction to what Betsy Ross has in her hands. And of course what Betsy Ross has in her hands is the American flag, the first design that most of us kind of know. It's a 13 red and white stripes. And in the upper left corner, that's called a canton. That's a blue square. And it has 13 five pointed stars arranged in a circle. Yeah. And the look on Washington's face is like, this is beautiful. Like, let me get my hands on it. I want it. He is in love. Yes. Yes. He's like, give me it. So over the years, the story was repeated over and over again, that Bessie Ross, flag maker to the stars, birth mother of the United States, created the first American flag.
摆脱英国的统治。这些戴假发的人正看着乔治·华盛顿，似乎在等待他对贝齐·罗斯手中的东西做出反应。当然，贝齐·罗斯手中的正是美国国旗，大多数人所熟知的第一个设计。它有13条红白相间的横条。左上角那个叫“州旗区”（canton），是一个蓝色方块。里面有13颗五角星排列成一个圆圈。是的。华盛顿脸上的表情就像是：这太美了。让我摸摸它。我想要它。他爱上它了。是的，是的。他就像是：把它给我。所以多年来，这个故事被反复讲述：贝齐·罗斯，明星旗帜制作者，美利坚合众国的生母，创造了第一面美国国旗。
But the story we learned in school, it's not exactly true. Oh no! Don't worry, she's still important, just not in the way we all think. Nobody knows where the first American flag is or who actually made it. This is Jennifer Jones. She's Curator at the National Museum of American History and she keeps a watchful eye over many of America's most important historical flags but notably not the flag in the Betsy Ross painting. I have never actually seen a 13 star in a circle original flag from the revolutionary period. So we really don't know what it looks like or if it still exists.
但我们在学校里学到的故事并不完全真实。哦，不！别担心，她依然很重要，只是不像我们所有人想的那样。没人知道第一面美国国旗在哪里，或者到底是谁制作了它。这是詹妮弗·琼斯（Jennifer Jones）。她是美国国家历史博物馆的馆长，她密切关注着许多美国最重要的历史旗帜，但值得注意的是，其中并不包括贝齐·罗斯画中的那面旗帜。我实际上从未见过革命时期那种13颗星排列成圆圈的原始旗帜。所以我们真的不知道它长什么样，或者它是否还存在。
So she doesn't know who made the first American flag. And she's never actually seen like a 13 star flag in a circle from that period at all. No. That's really something. So then where did the Betsy Ross thing come from? And she's never actually seen like a 13 star flag in a circle from that period at all. No. That's really something. So then where did the Betsy Ross thing come from? Well, if we back up, let's talk about what came before the Betsy Ross flag.
所以她不知道是谁制作了第一面美国国旗。而且她从未见过那个时期那种13颗星排列成圆圈的旗帜。没有。这真的很特别。那么贝齐·罗斯的故事是从哪儿来的呢？（重复）那么贝齐·罗斯的故事是从哪儿来的呢？好吧，如果我们回溯一下，让我们谈谈贝齐·罗斯旗帜之前是什么样的。
Prior to the Revolutionary War, there was a flag that was supposed to represent the colonies. It just had this problem. So we had a flag in 1776 that looked very much like a British flag. Right, and this is the grand union flag. It had 13 alternating red and white stripes just like our flag today.
在独立战争之前，有一面旗帜被认为代表了殖民地。它只是有这个问题。所以我们在1776年有一面看起来非常像英国国旗的旗帜。没错，这就是“大联盟旗”（Grand Union flag）。它有13条红白相间的横条，就像我们今天的国旗一样。
But in the corner, and that canton is sort of a blue square full of white stars and had a British cross, the Union Jack. Yeah, so members of the Continental Congress looked at the grand union flag and thought, how are we supposed to use a British flag when we're fighting the British? This is not a grand union. So on June 14th, 1777, they voted to create a new American flag.
但在角落里，那个州旗区是一个充满白星的蓝色方块，并且有英国的十字架，即联合杰克旗（Union Jack）。是的，所以大陆会议的成员们看着大联盟旗，心想：当我们正在与英国人作战时，我们怎么能使用一面英国旗帜呢？这不是什么大联盟。因此，在1777年6月14日，他们投票决定创造一面新的美国国旗。
And that is why we celebrate flag day on June 14th. Yes. And that thing that they voted for, Congress needed someone to design it. The congressman who is credited with actually establishing the look for the first flag was from New Jersey and its Francis Hopkinson. Have you ever heard of this guy? No, this is a name I do not know at all. So tell me about Francis Hopkinson. So Francis Hopkinson was a signer of the Declaration of Independence and kind of a Renaissance man.
这就是为什么我们在6月14日庆祝旗帜日。是的。他们投票决定的那个东西，国会需要有人来设计它。那位被认为真正确立了第一面旗帜外观的国会议员来自新泽西州，他就是弗朗西斯·霍普金森（Francis Hopkinson）。你听说过这个人吗？没有，这是一个我完全不知道的名字。所以跟我说说弗朗西斯·霍普金森。弗朗西斯·霍普金森是《独立宣言》的签署人之一，算是一位文艺复兴式的人物。
He wrote operas, he wrote songs, and he was one of the designers of the great seal of the United States. You've seen that one. It's the eagle clutching the arrows and you'll notice there's a shield, it's red, white, and blue with stars and stripes on it. This is Mark Leapson, historian and author of the book Flag, an American biography. He sent a bill to Congress, which is in the National Archives itself. And that bill says, you know, I'm charging you X amount of money for the design of the
他写歌剧，写歌，他还是美国国玺的设计者之一。你见过那个。那是老鹰抓着箭，你会注意到有一个盾牌，是红、白、蓝三色的，上面有星星和条纹。这是马克·利普森（Mark Leapson），历史学家，《旗帜：美国传记》一书的作者。他给国会寄了一张账单，现在就在国家档案馆里。那张账单上写着，你知道，我向你们收取设计费……
flag of the United States. So I have a copy of that bill that Hopkins incents Congress, and I love this because it's sort of an itemized invoice of all the stuff he helped the Continental Congress with. Designed in currency, the great seal, and yes, the flag. And in the last paragraph of the bill, Hopkins en writes, For these services, I have, as yet made, no charge, nor received any recompense. I now submit it to your honours consideration whether a quarter-cask of the public wine
美利坚合众国国旗的费用。所以我有一份霍普金森寄给国会的账单副本，我喜欢这个，因为它就像是一份他帮助大陆会议所做所有事情的明细发票。设计货币、国玺，还有，是的，旗帜。在账单的最后一段，霍普金森写道：“对于这些服务，我尚未收费，也未收到任何报酬。我现在提交给阁下考虑，四分之一桶公共葡萄酒是否是对这些奇思妙想劳动的适当且合理的奖励。”
will not be proper and reasonable reward for these labors of fancy. It's like the equivalent of like when you help your friends move and they give you pizza and beer, he's like, this is the least you can do, guys. Okay, so I mean, he says he designed the flag, there's a bill to prove it. That seems like that's the answer to the question
这就像当你帮朋友搬家，他们给你披萨和啤酒一样，他就像是：伙计们，这是你们至少能做的。好吧，我的意思是，他说他设计了旗帜，有一张账单可以证明。这似乎就是那个问题的答案：
who designed the flag. It seems to be, you know, Francis Hopkinson. Well, not quite. Because for all his talents, opera singer, graphic designer, Hopkinson wasn't known to so. Oh, so it's possible that he designed the flag and then George Washington asked Betsy Ross
谁设计了旗帜？似乎是，你知道，弗朗西斯·霍普金森。嗯，不完全是。因为尽管他才华横溢，是歌剧演员、平面设计师，但霍普金森并不以缝纫闻名。哦，所以有可能他设计了旗帜，然后乔治·华盛顿请贝齐·罗斯
to, you know, bring the Hopkinson, you know, design to life. It is. And ideally, there would be a paper trail laying all this history out, but there just isn't. And Mark Leapson says, there's a reason why. Nobody cared about the flag the way we do now. If you read the annals of the Continental Congress, the day that they passed the first
去，你知道，把霍普金森的设计变成现实。有可能。理想情况下，应该有一条记录所有这些历史的纸质线索，但根本没有。马克·利普森说，有一个原因。没人像我们现在这样关心旗帜。如果你阅读大陆会议的纪事，他们通过第一项
flag resolution, there's no mention of who introduced it. There's no mention of any vote or discussion. There's no mention of any flag committee. So it's a strong indication that it was just this thing that happened and they went on to it. And it didn't have a lot of meaning for people. It was like an administrative detail or something. It was like a footnote in the day.
旗帜决议的那一天，没有提到是谁提出的。没有提到任何投票或讨论。没有提到任何旗帜委员会。所以这强烈表明这只是发生的一件事，然后他们就继续下去了。它对人们没有太多意义。它就像一个行政细节之类的东西。它就像当天的一个脚注。
Yes, that's correct, but it's not even a footnote. It's a no note. It's not notable. No one noted it at all. I know, right? And the flag was so unimportant that the Continental Congress didn't even bother to specify where to put the stars and stripes. I asked Jennifer Jones about this.
是的，没错，但它甚至不是一个脚注。它是一个“无注”。它不值得注意。根本没人注意到它。我知道，对吧？而且这面旗帜太不重要了，以至于大陆会议甚至懒得指定星星和条纹放在哪里。我问了詹妮弗·琼斯这个问题。
So just to get this straight, according to the first flag act of 1777, I could make a flag that had like two stars up at the top for little eyes and then all the other stars arranged in a little smiley face and that would be an American flag. Correct. There was no set determination of any arrangement of the stars or the stripes. Wow, so people could play really fast and loose with the Hopkins design. Yeah, really fast and really loose, and that's not even the half of it, because the original plan for the flag was to add a star and stripe every time a state joined the union. Well, that would have been a mess. We had a lot of states in the 1800s.
所以为了弄清楚，根据1777年的第一部《旗帜法》，我可以制作一面旗帜，上面有两颗星作为小眼睛，然后所有其他星星排列成一个小笑脸，那也会是一面美国国旗。正确。对于星星或条纹的任何排列都没有设定规定。哇，所以人们可以非常随意地处理霍普金森的设计。是的，非常随意，而且这还不是全部，因为旗帜的最初计划是每当一个州加入联邦时就增加一颗星和一条纹。嗯，那会是一团糟。我们在19世纪有很多州。
It would have been a very big flag or you know, very narrow stripes. Yeah, it's a lot of seems to so. So yeah, flags would basically be made and almost immediately outdated. So people just could not keep up. So in 1818, Congress is like, all right, let's go back to the original 13 stripes
那会是一面非常大的旗帜，或者，你知道，非常窄的条纹。是的，这似乎太多了。所以，是的，旗帜基本上刚做出来就过时了。所以人们根本跟不上。因此在1818年，国会说，好吧，让我们回到最初的13条横条，
and then we can just put one star for each state every year on the 4th of July. Well, just like, it's like a system update, you know? Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. So that's what they did. And really not much else changed with the flag until 1861. There are very few things in history
然后我们可以在每年的7月4日为每个州增加一颗星。嗯，就像，这就像系统更新，你知道吗？是的，是的，这说得通。所以他们就是这么做的。而且直到1861年，旗帜确实没有太多变化。历史上很少有事情
that change almost immediately, but that's what happened with the flag. In April 1861, a rebel army captured Fort Sumter and raised a Confederate flag starting the Civil War. Almost overnight, when the war started in the North, you saw flags in front of people's houses, schools, churches, women wore little flags in their hats, the Pelpins, they put them on wagons.
会几乎立即发生变化，但旗帜就是这样。1861年4月，一支叛军占领了萨姆特堡，升起了一面邦联旗，引发了内战。几乎在一夜之间，当战争在北方开始时，你看到人们的房子、学校、教堂前都挂着旗帜，妇女们在帽子上戴着小旗帜，即徽章，他们把旗帜放在马车上。
And this is the time in American history where what historians call the cult of the flag started. For decades leading up to the war, the flag was basically used as an instrument of the military. It was a way to command troops on the field and command ships at sea. But during the Civil War, the flag became a symbol for the Union,
这是美国历史上所谓的“旗帜崇拜”开始的时期。在战争前的几十年里，旗帜基本上被用作军事工具。它是指挥战场上的部队和海上舰船的一种方式。但在内战期间，旗帜成为了联邦的象征，
something for Northerners to rally around. So it during the Civil War, the flag became a symbol for the Union, something for Northerners to rally around. So it was during this time that the flag went from being mostly a tool to an icon. And coincidentally, this is also the time when the legend of Betsy Ross first pops up. America did not know the name Betsy Ross until 1870, almost a hundred years after the fact.
北方人团结一致的某种东西。所以，在内战期间，旗帜成为了联邦的象征，北方人团结一致的某种东西。所以正是在这段时间里，旗帜从一种工具变成了一个偶像。巧合的是，这也是贝齐·罗斯的传说首次出现的时间。美国直到1870年，也就是事发近一百年后，才知道贝齐·罗斯这个名字。
And by this time, Betsy Ross was long dead, but her grandson, William Canby, he was alive and well, and he had grown up being told that his grandmother sowed the first American flag. So in 1870, he gave a speech to the Historical Society of Pennsylvania. This is President and Gentlemen of the Historical Society of Pennsylvania, a number of... This is a long speech that just kind of goes on. These facts being laid before the Executive Council of this Society... And on...
到那时，贝齐·罗斯早已去世，但她的孙子威廉·坎比（William Canby）还健在，他从小就被告知他的祖母缝制了第一面美国国旗。所以1870年，他在宾夕法尼亚州历史学会发表了一次演讲。这是“宾夕法尼亚州历史学会的主席和先生们，一些……”这是一次很长的演讲，只是有点没完没了。“这些事实被提交给本学会的执行委员会……”然后……
As the cellist commander at this time, no fake climmerings of independence could he not... And on. The leaders of the, were men of intelligence and experience in military matters. But then, it can be drops this bomb. He tells the crowd that the Continental Congress actually adopted the American flag during a secret session in early 1776.
“作为当时的大提琴指挥官，他怎么能没有独立的虚假呼声……”等等。领导人是军事事务中具有智慧和经验的人。但随后，坎比投下了这枚炸弹。他告诉人群，大陆会议实际上是在1776年初的一次秘密会议期间通过了美国国旗。
And then he reveals who made that flag that George Washington presented during that meeting. Elizabeth Betsy Ross, this is the lady, the one to whom belongs the honor of having made with her own hands the first flag. And almost overnight, Betsy Ross became a celebrity. The story really stuck with people. So how did this very long, reportedly kind of boring speech? Like, like capture the
然后他揭示了是谁制作了乔治·华盛顿在那次会议上展示的那面旗帜。伊丽莎白·贝齐·罗斯，这就是那位女士，那位亲手制作了第一面旗帜并享有荣誉的人。几乎在一夜之间，贝齐·罗斯成了名人。这个故事真的深入人心。那么，这个非常长、据说是有点无聊的演讲，是怎么
imagination enough to put Betsy Ross on a map like a hundred years after the fact. Well, Camby had impeccable timing. The country was healing after a brutal civil war and having a single flag was a powerful symbol. And people wanted to celebrate and have a story to tell about our country. At the same time, the women's suffrage movement was gaining momentum. So, with Betsy Ross' story, Americans didn't just have founding fathers to celebrate, they had a founding mother, too. But for historians like Mark Liebsen, can be story is a little flimsy. The Betsy Ross story is based 100% on family stories.
捕捉到人们的想象力，以至于在事发一百年后把贝齐·罗斯放在了地图上？好吧，坎比的时机把握得无懈可击。国家在残酷的内战后正在愈合，拥有一面统一的旗帜是一个强大的象征。人们想要庆祝，并有一个关于我们国家的故事可以讲述。与此同时，妇女选举权运动正在获得动力。所以，有了贝齐·罗斯的故事，美国人不仅有了可以庆祝的国父，还有了一位国母。但对于像马克·利普森这样的历史学家来说，坎比的故事有点站不住脚。贝齐·罗斯的故事100%基于家庭故事。
And if family, you know, when historians judge the merits of historical evidence, you know what's on the bottom? Oh, I bet family stories are the bottom. Yeah. It is my family, that's for sure. Yes, so let's take a closer look at the family story William can be told the Pennsylvania Historical Society in 1870. Where did he get that from? He got the story from Betsy's daughter Clarissa.
如果家庭，你知道，当历史学家评判历史证据的价值时，你知道最底层是什么吗？哦，我敢打赌家庭故事就是最底层。是的，这绝对是我的家庭。是的，所以让我们仔细看看威廉·坎比在1870年告诉宾夕法尼亚历史学会的那个家庭故事。他是从哪儿得到的？他从贝齐的女儿克拉丽莎（Clarissa）那里得到了这个故事。
This is Marla Miller, she's the author of Betsy Ross and the Making of America. She allegedly sits her nephew down while he says, I and says, I want you to take this down. This story is important. And she tells Will how his grandmother created the first flag. And Canvey's like, that is a great story, but what do people don't believe us? And so he asked all of these relatives to go to an attorney, go to a notary, and tell the story as you remember hearing it.
这是玛拉·米勒（Marla Miller），《贝齐·罗斯与美国的制造》的作者。她据称让她的侄子坐下来，当他说“我”时，她说：“我要你把它记下来。这个故事很重要。”她告诉威尔他的祖母是如何创造第一面旗帜的。坎比就像是：那是个伟大的故事，但如果人们不相信我们怎么办？于是他要求所有这些亲戚去找律师，去找公证人，并按照你记得听到的那样讲述这个故事。
And then that became sort of the archival basis for the story as it was in 1870. Oh, I see. So instead of the story getting distorted generation over generation, like a game of telephone, can be one to make sure at least the one in 1870 was locked and frozen in time, and that he had receipts. Like, he got him notarized and everything. Yeah, like, he left a voicemail. I mean, I guess that a bunch of people
然后这就成了1870年那个故事的档案基础。哦，我明白了。所以故事不是像传声筒游戏那样一代代被扭曲，坎比想要确保至少1870年的那个版本被锁定并冻结在时间里，而且他有收据。就像，他把它们公证了，诸如此类。是的，就像，他留下了语音信箱。我的意思是，我猜有一群人
writing it down, getting it notarized, does add some credibility that it's more than just an old family story. Yeah, I think it was kind of the best he could do at that point. And so, the Ross family story, it is a big hit. And it sort of starts to take on a life of its own. When I do talks, I, when I get to Betsy Ross,
把它写下来，进行公证，确实增加了一些可信度，证明它不仅仅是一个古老的家庭故事。是的，我认为这在当时是他能做的最好的了。所以，罗斯家族的故事，它是一个巨大的成功。它开始有了自己的生命。当我做演讲时，我，当我讲到贝齐·罗斯时，
I say, you know, I know what you're thinking, right? They're thinking of that picture. You know, Betsy Ross sitting in her parlor on Arch Street. And this is the painting that we were talking about earlier. Yes. That picture is completely made up. Of course, it was painted in 1893, 115 years after the fact. Yeah.
我说，你知道，我知道你在想什么，对吧？他们想到的是那张照片。你知道，贝齐·罗斯坐在拱街的客厅里。这就是我们之前谈到的那幅油画。是的。那张照片完全是编造的。当然，它是1893年画的，事发115年后。是的。
The painting, the birth of our nation's flag, was done by this guy named Charles Weisgerber, and it is entirely a product of his imagination. It was part of Weisgerber's promotion of the Betsy Ross myth and not coincidentally, the Betsy Ross house, which he owned, and was his tourist attraction. Vice-Curber was such a Betsy Ross superfan that he actually bought what he thought was the house she grew up in, although the neighborhoods in Philadelphia have changed so much. It's hard to say if it actually was. Yeah, okay.
这幅画《我们国家国旗的诞生》是由一个叫查尔斯·韦斯格伯（Charles Weisgerber）的人完成的，它完全是他想象的产物。它是韦斯格伯推广贝齐·罗斯神话的一部分，而且并非巧合的是，贝齐·罗斯故居也是他拥有的，是他的旅游景点。韦斯格伯是贝齐·罗斯的超级粉丝，他甚至买下了他认为是她长大的房子，尽管费城的街区已经发生了很大变化。很难说它是否真的是。是的，好吧。
I don't want to say it was a Huckster, but he was a real good promoter, okay? I mean, Huckster implies that he wasn't genuine, but he even went to Vincenuine. Yeah, I mean, he did spend the rest of his life promoting Vetzy Ross' legacy. He even named his son, Vexel Domus, which you know what that's Latin for, right? They just kid flag house. Yes. Yes, he did. He's committed to the bit. All right. They just kid flag house. Yes. Yes. Oh. Yes, he did. He's committed to the bit.
我不想说他是个骗子，但他是一个非常好的推销员，好吗？我的意思是，骗子暗示他不真诚，但他甚至去了文森斯。是的，我的意思是，他确实花了一辈子时间推广贝齐·罗斯的遗产。他甚至给他的儿子取名为“Vexel Domus”，你知道那是拉丁语，对吧？他们只是“旗帜之家”。是的。是的，他做到了。他致力于这个角色。好吧。他们只是“旗帜之家”。是的。是的。哦。是的，他做到了。他致力于这个角色。
Yeah. He even dressed Vexel up in an uncle's Samsung suit and paraded him around the Betsy Ross house presiding patriotic quotes for visitors. Oh, I love everything about what you just said. It was like my only problem with it is I wasn't there to see it. Oh. what you just said. My only problem with it is I wasn't there to see it.
是的。他甚至把Vexel打扮成山姆大叔的套装，带着他在贝齐·罗斯故居周围游行，为游客朗诵爱国名言。哦，我喜欢你刚才说的关于它的一切。就像我唯一的问题是当时我不在场，没能看到。哦。你刚才说的。我唯一的问题是当时我不在场，没能看到。
Yeah, so thanks in part to Weiss Gerber, Betsy Ross' story was permanently woven into the American fabric. And yes, historians have tried to correct the record ever since, but the myth persists. So if we dispense with the myth, who actually was Betsy Ross? Alright, let's take it back to the beginning. Betsy Ross was born Elizabeth Griscombe, and she was one of 18 children. Not all survived to adulthood as is common in that time and place, but she was in the middle of a big family, so she had, you know,
是的，所以部分归功于韦斯格伯，贝齐·罗斯的故事被永久地编织进了美国的结构中。是的，历史学家们从那时起就一直试图纠正记录，但神话依然存在。所以如果我们抛开神话，贝齐·罗斯到底是谁？好吧，让我们回到开始。贝齐·罗斯出生时叫伊丽莎白·格里斯科姆（Elizabeth Griscombe），她是18个孩子之一。并非所有人都活到了成年，这在那个时代和地方很常见，但她在一个大家庭中排行中间，所以她有，你知道，
these several older sisters. And at the age of 21, she rebelled against her strict quaker upbringing by marrying John Ross, who was not a quaker, and this sort of put her on the outs with her family. So she and John ran off to the big city, Philadelphia, and they opened up in a poultry shop, and things were really good for a couple of years until John died. So there she is, it's January of 76, and she's a young widow. And at that time, in the course of the revolution, Philadelphia is fearful that the British Navy is going to appear.
这几个姐姐。21岁时，她通过嫁给约翰·罗斯（John Ross）反抗了她严格的贵格会教养，约翰不是贵格会教徒，这使她与家人的关系疏远了。所以她和约翰跑到了大城市费城，他们开了一家装潢店，几年里生意非常好，直到约翰去世。所以她就在那里，那是76年1月，她是一个年轻的寡妇。当时，在革命的过程中，费城担心英国海军会出现。
They're worried they're going to be invaded. And so there is a mad scramble to create what's essentially the first navy. And what does the navy need besides ships? Well, they need flags. Right. And anyone who could push a needle through a piece of fabric was competing for government contracts to sow these flags. It didn't matter if you are dressmaker, a saddler, and a polsterer, the government was desperate for flags. And Betsy Ross, no longer had her family or a husband to help supporter, she was desperate too. Betsy Ross saw that happening in need of an income, newly widowed, and wanted to get
他们担心会被入侵。所以人们疯狂地争抢着建立本质上的第一支海军。海军除了船还需要什么？好吧，他们需要旗帜。没错。任何能把针穿过布料的人都在竞争政府合同来缝制这些旗帜。无论你是裁缝、马具商还是装潢工，政府都急需旗帜。而贝齐·罗斯，不再有家人或丈夫来帮助支持她，她也很绝望。贝齐·罗斯看到了这种情况，需要收入，刚守寡，想进入
on the rolodex for those contracts. And so I always say like, it's Betsy Ross government contractor is what we need to be thinking. Okay, so if this was like a game of clue and we've got like Betsy Ross government contractor in Philadelphia in 1776. So all this stuff is there for her to be the person who sowed the first flag. But is there any other evidence that any part of the story we're heard in school is true? Well, it's all pretty circumstantial. Marlamiller says historical records put George Washington in Philadelphia the month this was all said to take place. So that checks out.
那些合同的通讯录。所以我总是说，就像，贝齐·罗斯是政府承包商，这是我们需要思考的。好吧，所以如果这就像一场《妙探寻凶》（Clue）游戏，我们有贝齐·罗斯，政府承包商，1776年的费城。所以所有这些东西都在那里，让她成为缝制第一面旗帜的人。但还有其他证据表明我们在学校听到的故事的任何部分是真的吗？好吧，这都是相当间接的。玛拉·米勒说，历史记录显示乔治·华盛顿在这一切据说发生的那个月就在费城。所以这说得通。
And actually one of the men who allegedly joined the visit to Betsy Ross' shop is George Ross, Betsy Ross' uncle, who actually knew Washington. So the logic goes, he could have made the introduction. But Marlamiller says the story gets a key detail about him wrong. George Ross was not a member of Congress in the spring of 76. He's elected later that year. I believe at the end of the summer.
而且实际上，据称加入访问贝齐·罗斯商店的其中一个人是乔治·罗斯（George Ross），贝齐·罗斯的叔叔，他确实认识华盛顿。所以逻辑是，他本可以进行介绍。但玛拉·米勒说，故事中关于他的一个关键细节是错误的。乔治·罗斯在76年春天不是国会议员。他是在那年晚些时候当选的。我相信是在夏末。
And so he would not have been on a congressional committee charged with acquiring a new flag. Huh. Yeah, and that's not the only problem with the story. The other powdered wig who supposedly joined Washington on that trip to Betsy Ross' shop, acquiring a new flag. Huh. Yeah, and that's not the only problem with the story. The other powdered wig who supposedly joined Washington on that trip to Betsy Ross' shop, he was famously opposed to American independence.
所以他不会在负责获取新旗帜的国会委员会中。嗯。是的，而且这并不是故事中唯一的问题。那个据称在去贝齐·罗斯商店的路上加入华盛顿的另一个戴假发的人，获取新旗帜。嗯。是的，而且这并不是故事中唯一的问题。那个据称在去贝齐·罗斯商店的路上加入华盛顿的另一个戴假发的人，
So that doesn't make sense. Okay, so Marlem Miller doesn't seem to think that there's much truth to this whole scene at the Betsy Ross shop. No, lots of it does not pass the smell test, but she did say that there is one thing that rings true to her. And you'll like this Roman because it has to do with design. Excellent, okay, design.
他以反对美国独立而闻名。所以这说不通。好吧，所以玛拉·米勒似乎不认为贝齐·罗斯商店的整个场景有多少真实性。没有，很多都经不起推敲，但她确实说有一件事对她来说是真实的。你会喜欢这个的，罗曼，因为它与设计有关。太棒了，好吧，设计。
Hit me. Okay, so remember how we said Frances Hopkinson designed the first flag? Yes, I could never forget Frances Hopkinson. Well, many historians think that the first flag Hopkinson designed for the US had six pointed stars on it. And that would be consistent with heraldry design at the time and the other things that he designed for the revolution. So Marla Miller thinks it's Hopkinson's six-pointed star design that George Washington ultimately showed Betsy Ross. But Betsy, being a skilled seamstress, she's like, well, if you're gonna need a lot of these flags,
告诉我。好吧，还记得我们说弗朗西斯·霍普金森设计了第一面旗帜吗？是的，我永远不会忘记弗朗西斯·霍普金森。好吧，许多历史学家认为霍普金森为美国设计的第一面旗帜上有六角星。这与当时的纹章设计以及他为革命设计的其他东西是一致的。所以玛拉·米勒认为，乔治·华盛顿最终展示给贝齐·罗斯看的是霍普金森的六角星设计。但贝齐，作为一名熟练的裁缝，她就像是：好吧，如果你需要很多这样的旗帜，
let me show you a little shortcut. She pulls out, we don't know if it's fabric, we don't know if it's paper, but she folds out a little scrap, just so, folds it up just so, and with one snip of the scissors, out pops this five-pointed star. Miller says this, the five-pointed star,
让我给你展示一个小捷径。她拿出来，我们不知道是布料还是纸，但她折叠了一个小碎片，就这样，折叠得恰到好处，随着剪刀的一剪，这颗五角星就出来了。米勒说这个，五角星，
is likely Betsy Ross' contribution to the American flag. That story is not her saying I made the first flag. What she was proud of, and this just resonates with everything we know about the period, is that the father of our country, you know, the nation's biggest celebrity in that period, came into her shop and she taught him something. That resonates for me.
很可能是贝齐·罗斯对美国国旗的贡献。那个故事不是她说“我制作了第一面旗帜”。她引以为豪的是，这与我们所知的关于那个时期的一切产生了共鸣，那就是我们国家的国父，你知道，那个时期国家最大的名人，走进了她的店，她教了他一些东西。这对我来说产生了共鸣。
That's the kind of moment a woman like her would remember forever. This is really interesting because in Heraldry, the five-pointing star is pretty recent. It showed up here and there, but its prominence on the US flag is said to have really caused it to take off on many other flags that followed. Yeah, so Betsy Ross could have been behind that shift.
那是像她这样的女人会永远记住的时刻。这真的很有趣，因为在纹章学中，五角星是相当近期的。它在这里和那里出现过，但它在美国国旗上的突出地位据说确实使它在随后的许多其他旗帜上流行起来。是的，所以贝齐·罗斯可能是那个转变背后的推手。
And there is another clue Miller uncovered while researching her book to support the star version of the story. It's still something from a family member, but from a different perspective. One of Betsy's extended family members is an illustrator named Joseph Boggs' Beale. He was very important to the 19th century as an artist. Miller came across one of Boggs' Beale's diaries, and while she's leaving through it, she finds an entry from February 1857. Boggs' Beale is over at Cloris's house
而且米勒在研究她的书时发现了另一个线索来支持故事的星星版本。它仍然是来自家庭成员的东西，但从不同的角度。贝齐的一位远房亲戚是一位名叫约瑟夫·博格斯·比尔（Joseph Boggs Beale）的插画家。作为一名艺术家，他对19世纪非常重要。米勒偶然发现了博格斯·比尔的一本日记，当她翻阅时，她发现了一篇1857年2月的条目。博格斯·比尔在克拉丽莎家
for a big family gathering. All the players are there. And in the diary, although he's an artist, there are no other doodles. At the bottom of this page is a five-pointed star. And I looked at that and it gave me a chill and it's hard not to think. He came home from that and wrote up, you know, his evening, and that he heard a story that
参加一个大家庭聚会。所有相关人员都在那里。在日记中，尽管他是一位艺术家，但没有其他涂鸦。在这一页的底部是一颗五角星。我看着它，它让我感到一阵寒意，很难不认为。他从那里回家后写下了，你知道，他的夜晚，他那天晚上听到了一个关于五角星的故事。所以家庭故事可能有一些真实性，或者它们可能只是那样，故事。但玛拉·米勒说这并不重要。她认为这就是执着于“第一”的问题。我们真的错过了贝齐·罗斯故事的其余部分。我的意思是，当那个旗帜时刻，无论它是什么，展开时，她是一个20出头的女人。然后她就继续了这段漫长而有趣的职业生涯。她第二次结婚，第二次守寡，她在1777年费城的占领中幸存下来。
night about a five-pointed star. So the family stories could have some truth, or they could be just that, stories. But Marlemiller says it doesn't really matter. She thinks this is the problem with being fixated on the first. We really miss the rest of the Betsy Ross story. I mean, she was a woman in her early 20s when that flag moment, whatever it was, unfolded. And then she just goes on to this long and interesting career. She marries a second time, she's widowed a second time, she survives the occupation of Philadelphia in 1777.
她的儿子和侄子后来成为了船长，她关注全球事件，她写信给海军部提醒他们，比如“我还在营业，你们需要什么吗？”就像她的世界非常广阔。这就是为什么客厅的图像真的让我感到不舒服，因为她的视野很广阔，并没有局限于那个客厅，而且肯定没有局限于1976年。当我们回来时，一面我们知道存在并且我们知道是谁制作的旗帜，稍后回来。所以我又和莉齐·皮博迪在一起了，你还有另一个故事要告诉我们，可能会破坏我们在80年代接受的小学教育，是这样吗？你知道我破坏每个人的小学教育。
Her sons and nephews go on to be ship captains, she is paying attention to global events, she is writing the Navy Department to remind them like I'm still in business, do you need anything? Like her world is so big. And that's why that the parlor images really get under my skin because her horizons were broad they weren't confined to that parlor and they certainly weren't confined 1976. When we come back, a flag that we know exists and we know who made it to after this. So I'm back with Lizzie Peabody and you have another story for us that might undermine our elementary school education that we had in the 80s, is that right? You know me undermining everyone's elementary school education.
一次一个故事。太棒了。是的，所以我确实有另一个故事，这个故事是我在报道贝齐·罗斯旗帜的那篇文章时偶然发现的。所以在报道这篇文章时，我去了美国国家历史博物馆，因为那似乎是寻找贝齐·罗斯旗帜的地方。绝对，那是我会去寻找的地方，而且既然你有地理优势。那就是我想象你会去寻找的地方。没错，但你知道，正如我们所知，我去了那里与馆长詹妮弗·琼斯聊天，
One story at a time. Excellent. Yeah, so I do have another story and this one I sort of found by accident while reporting the piece on the Betsy Ross flag So while reporting this piece I went to the National Museum of American History Because that seemed like the place to go to find the Betsy Ross flag Absolutely, that's where I'd look and since you have proximity. That's where I would imagine you would look Right, but you know as we know, I went over there to chat with Curator Jennifer Jones,
她无法向我展示那面旗帜。没错，因为它不存在。是的，向某人展示不存在的东西是非常困难的。但她确实有一面旗帜可以展示给我，这一面确实存在，而且它可能比所谓的贝齐·罗斯旗帜更出名。
and she could not show me the flag. Right, because it does not exist. Yes, and it's very hard to show somebody something that doesn't exist. But she did have a flag that she could show me, and this one does exist, and it is arguably more famous than the so-called Betsy Ross flag.
所以这就是《星条旗》（Star Spangled Banner）。这就是《星条旗》，没错。所以只有一面《星条旗》。没错。就是这面旗帜。正确。所以很多人可能听到《星条旗》会立刻想到，哦，国歌。
So this is the Star Spangled Banner. This is the Star Spangled Banner, that's correct. So there's only one Star Spangled Banner. That's right. And it's this flag. Correct. So a lot of people probably hear Star Spangled Banner and immediately think, oh, the national anthem.
没错。但《星条旗》并不那么强。它就像是一面来自1812年战争的真实、有形的旗帜，你可以亲自去看看。是的，你可以，我也去了。罗曼，你去过史密森尼学会看它吗？我没有。我去过史密森尼学会的很多地方，实际上现在已经是很久以前的事了，但我现在不记得专门看过那个。所以这是一面15颗星、15条横条的旗帜，它就在詹妮弗·琼斯所说的博物馆的心脏地带。所以当你从正门进去时，你从主干道转进这条黑暗的走廊，
Right. But the Star Spangled Banner isn't as strong. It's like a real tangible flag from the War of 1812 that you can actually go see. Yes, you can, and I did. Have you ever been to see it at the Smithsonian, Roman? I have not. I've been to lots of parts of the Smithsonian, like actually quite a while ago at this point, but I don't remember seeing that specifically now. So it's a 15-star, 15-stripe flag, and it's right in what Jennifer Jones calls the heart of the museum. So when you go in the main entrance, you sort of turn off the main drag down this dark hallway,
它通向这个像电影院一样的房间。在你面前的是这面旗帜，铺在密封室的玻璃后面，这保护它免受损坏。那里大约有14%的氧气。哦，哇。我们呼吸大约22%的氧气。所以当我们进去时，必须两个人一起进去。必须两个人一起进去，以防一个人因缺氧而昏倒。没错。
and it opens out into this movie theater-like room. And in front of you is the flag laid out behind glass in this sealed chamber which protects it from breaking down. It's about 14% oxygen in there. Oh wow. We breathe about 22% oxygen. And so when we go in there, two people have to go in. Two people have to go in in case one person passes out for lack of oxygen. That's right.
天哪。当你走进去时，你会头痛。保护工作是危险的工作。我想这就是为什么……不知道。我当时想，没有氧气怎么样？天哪，当你走进去时，你会头痛。保护工作是危险的工作。我想这就是为什么……不知道。我当时想，没有氧气怎么样？如果真的成了问题，但现在我明白了原因，好吧。是的，我也很震惊。
Oh my gosh. You get a big headache when you walk in there. Conservation is dangerous work. I guess that's why no idea. I was like, how about no oxygen? Gosh, you get a big headache when you walk in there. Conservation is dangerous work. I guess that's why no idea. I was like, how about no oxygen? If it really comes to a problem, but now I see why, okay. Yes, I was pretty shocked too.
所以这是我想说的，罗曼。《星条旗》，这面我们确实拥有的旗帜，我们实际上确实知道是谁制作的。哦，太好了。嗯，这是一种解脱。我们100%确定知道是谁制作了《星条旗》。哦，太好了。嗯，这是一种解脱。我们100%确定知道是谁制作了《星条旗》。它的销售账单在巴尔的摩的国家旗帜之家和博物馆里。它是由一位名叫玛丽·皮克斯吉尔（Mary Pickersgill）的女士制作的。你
So here's the thing that I wanted to get to Roman. The star-spangled banner, this flag that we do have, we actually do know who made it. Oh, good. Well, that's a relief. We know 100% do know who made it. Oh, good. Well, that's a relief. We know 100% for sure who made the star Spangled Banner. The bill of sale for that is in the National Flaghouse and Museum in Baltimore. It was made by a woman named Mary Pickerskill. You
在四年级时没有学过玛丽·皮克斯吉尔。没有。为什么？她没有查尔斯·韦斯格伯，对吧？她没有宣传机器在运转。哈哈。哈哈。所以跟我多说说玛丽·皮克斯吉尔。好的，所以我喜欢这个，因为以一种奇怪的方式，玛丽·皮克斯吉尔的故事与贝齐·罗斯的故事平行。玛丽·皮克斯吉尔来自一个旗帜制作家庭。
didn't learn about Mary Pickerskill in fourth grade. No. Why? She didn't have a Charles Weiss Gerber, right? She didn't have the publicity machine going. Ha, ha, ha. Ha. So tell me more about Mary Pickerskill. OK, so I love this because in a strange way, Mary Pickerskill's story runs parallel with Betsy Rosses. Mary Pickerswell comes from a family of flag makers.
她的母亲丽贝卡·杨（Rebecca Young）在革命期间为乔治·华盛顿的大陆军缝制旗帜。事实上，杨和贝齐·罗斯住在同一时间的费城，所以她们是同时代的人，可能认识彼此。所以有人认为丽贝卡·杨实际上缝制了贝齐·罗斯的旗帜吗？
Her mom, Rebecca Young, was known to sew flags during the revolution for George Washington's Continental Army. And in fact, Young lived in Philadelphia at the same time as Betsy Ross, so they were contemporaries in might have known each other. So is there any thought that Rebecca Young actually, sewed the Betsy Ross flag?
我们又要打开潘多拉的盒子了。是的，我知道。所以这个家庭实际上声称——我们又要进入家庭故事了——杨缝制了华盛顿飞行的第一面大联盟旗。所以有一种思想流派说，嘿，有一些间接证据表明丽贝卡·杨可能也与贝齐·罗斯的旗帜有关。我们真的不知道。但我们确实对她的女儿玛丽·皮克斯吉尔了解很多，
We're reopening the can of worms. Yeah, I know. So the family actually claims, and here we go into family stories again, that young sewed the first grand union flag that Washington flew. So there's a school thought that says, hey, there's some circumstantial evidence to say Rebecca, young might have had something to do with the Betsy Ross flag too. We really don't know. But we do know a lot about her daughter, Mary Pickers' Gill,
她像贝齐·罗斯一样，年轻时守寡，也开始制作旗帜来养家糊口。在1805年丈夫去世后，玛丽和她的母亲搬到了巴尔的摩。几年后，1812年战争正在进行，我们又在与英国人作战。正是在1813年的夏天，当时37岁的皮克斯吉尔被麦克亨利堡（Fort McHenry，巴尔的摩的堡垒）的领导人要求制作一面非常大的旗帜。具体来说，我想他说的是一面旗帜，引用，
who, like Betsy Ross, was widowed at a young age and also took up flag making to support her family. And after the death of her husband in 1805, Mary and her mom moved to Baltimore. And a few years later, the war of 1812's underway, and we're fighting the British again. And it's in the summer of 1813 that Pickersgill, who is 37 years old at the time, is asked by the leaders of Fort McHenry, the Fort in Baltimore, to make a very large flag. Specifically, I think he said a flag that was, quote,
“大到英国人从远处看都不会有任何问题”。你想要它像一面“当面”的旗帜，就像，就像阵亡将士纪念日的汽车经销商风格的旗帜。没错。所以这就是为什么他们把它做成30英尺乘42英尺。它实际上太大了，他们不得不把缝纫工作转移到附近的啤酒厂，因为旗帜比他们房子的占地面积还要大。所以玛丽·皮克斯吉尔花了六周时间没日没夜地缝制才完成了这面旗帜，但她并不是一个人完成的。她有她母亲、女儿、两个侄女的帮助，
so large that the British will have no trouble seeing it from a distance. You want it like an in your face flag, like, like a car dealership on Memorial Day, style flag. Exactly. So that's why they made it 30 feet by 42 feet. And it was actually so big, they had to move their sewing operations to a nearby brewery because the flag was larger than the footprint of their house. So it took Mary Picker's girl six weeks of around the clock sewing to finish the flag, but she did not do it alone. She had the help of her mother, her daughter, two nieces,
还有一个名叫格蕾丝·威舍（Grace Wisher）的契约仆人。实际上有一幅画描绘了这面旗帜正在缝制的时刻，也是在事后很久才完成的。是的。好吧，所以我又看到了另一个穿着蓬蓬裙坐着的女人。这次她拿着一面相当大的旗帜。例如，星星和她的躯干一样大。在前面，在前景中，实际上很难辨认。有一条虚线，是那个你提到的失踪人员，那个契约仆人。是的，看起来她拿着灯笼之类的东西。是的，是的。
and an indentured servant named Grace Wisher. And there's actually a painting of the moment this flag was being sewn, Also done well after the fact. Yeah. Okay, so I see again another woman in a poofy dress sitting down. This time she is holding a flag of considerable size. Like the star is as big as her torso, for example. And up front, in the foreground, it's actually kind of hard to make out. There's a dashed line of the sort of missing person, the indentured servant that you mentioned. Yeah, it looks like she's holding a lantern or something. Yeah, yeah.
所以当旗帜完成时，它重约50磅，它被升上旗杆供所有人观看。正是这幅美丽的旗帜在巴尔的摩战役后的早晨高高飘扬的画面，激励了弗朗西斯·斯科特·基（Francis Scott Key），对吧？没错。写下了我们都知道的那首歌，《星条旗》。嗯，我的意思是，这是一幅她缝制那面旗帜的非常引人注目的画面。可惜她没有韦斯格伯以同样的方式推广贝齐·罗斯故事那样推广它，但你可以成为这个故事的韦斯格伯，我想。你可以。好的。
So by the time the flag was finished, it weighed about 50 pounds, and it was hoisted up the flag pole for all to see. And it's this image of a beautiful flag flying high, the morning after battle of Baltimore that inspires Francis Conquay, right? Right. To write the song we all know, the starsfangled banner. Well, I mean, this is a really striking image of her sewing that flag. It's too bad that she didn't have a white scurber to promote it the same way that Betsy Ross story was promoted, but you can be the white scurber of this story, as opposed. Where you can. OK.
玛丽·皮克斯吉尔有罗曼·马斯。她不需要韦斯格伯。没错。好吧，非常感谢你讲述这个故事。也感谢你在《侧门》播客中所做的所有工作。我真的很喜欢它。好吧，非常感谢。能和你分享这个故事真是太荣幸了。
Mary Pickersdale has a Roman Mars. She doesn't need a white scurber. That's right. Well, thank you so much for telling the story. And thanks for all the work you do on the Sidedoor podcast. I really enjoy it. Well, thanks so much. It's been such a pleasure sharing this story with you.
玛丽·皮克斯代尔有一个罗曼·马尔斯。她不需要白色的擦洗器。没错。好的，非常感谢你讲述这个故事。也感谢你在《侧门》播客中所做的一切工作。我真的很喜欢它。好的，非常感谢。能和你分享这个故事真是太荣幸了。
99% Invisible was produced and edited this week by Lizzie Peabody, James Morrison, and Jason De Leon. Mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales, music by our director of sound, Swan Rial. Fact checker, Sona Avakin. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, Kurt Coleset is the digital director. Special welcome this week to our intern, Sarah Baker. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroubaix, Christopher Johnson, Washmadan, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars.
本周的《99% Invisible》由Lizzie Peabody、James Morrison和Jason De Leon制作并编辑。混音与技术制作由Martin Gonzales负责，音乐由我们的声音总监Swan Rial创作。事实核查员是Sona Avakin。Delaney Hall担任执行制片人，Kurt Coleset担任数字总监。本周特别欢迎我们的实习生Sarah Baker。团队其他成员包括Emmett Fitzgerald、Vivian Leigh、Joe Rosenberg、Chris Baroubaix、Christopher Johnson、Washmadan、Sophia Klatsker以及我，Roman Mars。
Special thanks to the team at Sintor and Kananon, Jess Saudec, Sharon Bryant, Lyra Koch and Tamionio. If you want to hear more stories that span history, art, science and culture, you can find Scyndor by visiting the Smithsonian site at SI.edu or wherever you're listening to this podcast. 99% invisible is part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram and read it
特别感谢Sintor和Kananon团队、Jess Saudec、Sharon Bryant、Lyra Koch以及Tamionio。如果您想收听更多涵盖历史、艺术、科学和文化的节目，可以访问史密森尼学会网站SI.edu或在您收听本播客的任何平台找到Scyndor。《99% Invisible》是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一员，目前总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，环境优美。您可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。您可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg，或者在Instagram和Reddit上关注我们。
too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Okay, my apologies for this. Oh, say can you stature? From serious sex sound? Say can you stature? Browse here, yes, exam. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您也可以在99PI.org找到我喜爱的其他Stitcher节目，以及《99% Invisible》的所有往期剧集。好吧，对此我深表歉意。哦，你能看到吗？来自Sirius XM的声音？你能看到吗？在此浏览，是的，检查一下。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。